wir haben einen alten Bauernhof gekauft
und als wir vor ein paar Tagen
eingezogen sind dachte ich ehrlich
gesagt dass wir erstmal volle Kanne mit
renovieren beschäftigt werden aber
Pustekuchen ich habe überhaupt nicht
damit gerechnet dass der Garten so
voller Obst hängen würde diese ganzen
Beeren und Kirschen sind überreift die
müssen dringend verarbeitet werden und
wenn ich eine Sache hasse dann sind es
Früchte die am Baum verschimmelt
deswegen lassen wir alle
Renovierungsarbeiten ruhen und kümmern
uns erstmal darum dass jedes Früchtchen
aus diesem wunderschönen Garten auch
seine Verwendung findet ich habe zum
Beispiel fruchtleder hergestellt und
diesen unfassbar leckeren Saft das ist
nämlich viel zu viel Obst um das alles
frisch zu essen deswegen machen wir ganz
viel für den Winter haltbar kleiner
Trick falls ihr auch Bären einfrieren
wollt verteilt die erstmal lose auf so
einem Backblech und friert die für ein
paar Stunden an dann Klumpen sie nämlich
später abgefüllt nicht mehr zusammen
wenn ihr noch mehr Tricks und Tipps zum
haltbar machen lernen wollt dann schaut
mal unter diesem Link vorbei da findet
ihr meinen Kurs